we have a voicemail number that you can
call and leave me a voicemail that
number is 219 to David P here is a
caller Furious that I'm not talking
about alien spaceships take a listen to
this
hey Dave Steve in San Diego yes sir
you're a vexing Cosmic conscience
calling in once again to challenge you
on your utter failure to address the
most important story in the history of
the planet which is UFOs are real we
have now totally accredited all the
justification and backing in the world
type guy who has just come out an
official whistleblower saying look that
it is real you have to deal with it stop
playing games okay you might you my
friend are playing games still you
ignore the story you don't want to cover
it you've minimized it you've dismissed
it instead let's go yet another segment
on why Donald Trump is bad and how you
can look all Superior and smarmy
pointing that out whether or not Donald
Trump is bad is not the point point is
you would rather cover nonsense than the
most important story ever and the answer
must be that you're afraid you're afraid
Dave I'm calling you out why because if
UFOs are real and they are then it calls
into questions and undermines everything
that you're
touting as being so important to cover
that is quite a conspiracy theory now I
think it's really important to mention
when you say UFOs are real all you're
saying is there have been flying objects
that were unidentified
what this caller means and what this
caller is referring to is that
intelligent aliens with spaceships are
real I've acknowledged UFOs are real in
the sense that there have been flying
objects that we did not at least
immediately identify
that is very different than what is now
being said now what is this individual
referring to two days ago
two alleged whistleblowers have come
forward and have said the U.S has in its
possession intact alien Vehicles they
are not from China or Russia we know
that these are from aliens from other
planets we have intact vehicles and it
is being covered up now when you say I'm
scared to cover it what exactly would I
say because these are claims from two
people
they've not been verified by any
independent source and no evidence has
been presented so given that there's no
evidence what exactly could I say now
the conspiracy theorist will say right
but David they're hiding the evidence
the fact remains we have no evidence
the claims of these two people in the
last couple days have been contradicted
by the official report on unidentified
aerial phenomena that the Pentagon
released in 2021 now folks like this
caller will say but that report is part
of the effort to deceive people and to
hide the truth
I don't have evidence of that and that
sort of depends on whether you trust
these two people
or whether you trust the report that was
published what do you prefer to rely
upon either way
uh I don't have evidence to support what
this caller is telling me so it's tough
when people say you're not covering it
you should be covering it you're afraid
to cover it what exactly could I add to
the story
there are unproven claims from one or
maybe two people
for which no evidence has been presented
which some people see and say that's the
cover-up that's the conspiracy I don't
know what you want me to say about it
because not only do I not have evidence
for the claims being made I also don't
have evidence that there is any cover-up
taking place and I know that
conspiracy-minded people say that's the
evidence of the conspiracy absence of
evidence is evidence
but that's not really the type of show
this is we have to deal in empiricism
and reality and evidence so I'm open to
hearing from the audience is this a
story I should be aggressively covering
should I be all over the claims of one
or maybe two people that the U.S has
intact alien spacecraft absent any
evidence suggesting that that's the case
or is there not very much for me to say
about it let me know what you think and
I will be guided by the audience we are
going to have such a great bonus show
for you today oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yes everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad assisting Us in making money on
today's bonus show we're going to talk
about another explosive Republican
campaign launch for president the
governor of North Dakota Doug burgum is
running I know I know you've never heard
of them but he's running okay we'll talk
about it number two the group moms for
Liberty has been designated an extremist
group and Trump's a big fan of the group
we will talk about that and number three
by popular demand we will talk about the
Apple Vision Pro
this has been revealed by Apple
um I have many thoughts we will discuss
them on the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com don't miss today's bonus
show produced every single weekday for
our members and you can use the coupon
code indicted very relevant coupon code
today to get a discount at
joinpakman.com I'll see you then or
we'll be back here tomorrow for the
Friday show